(audience applauding)
May I please ask you.
Oh!
I'm so fascinated.
You, like, did a talk show.
What did you think and feel?
Like, sometimes I go home at night and think,
"Do people think I ask them appropriate questions?"
Like, you know, I have all these questions every night.
I really do. I, like, stare up...
Like, should I sit on the floor when I'm talking to you?
Is that gonna come off weird?
But it's what I'm inclined to do.
(audience applauds)
Drew, I think you just be you, all right?
And if it means getting down on the floor like this,
this is what we do.
(audience applauds)
My, my knees are killing me.
Okay, we can,
thank you!
Excuse my tuna breath!
Did you, did you,
yeah that but I, no, I, you, you, you really,
'Cause I loved your talk show. It was great!
That was a weird moment wasn't it?
(audience laughs)
You really just, I've never seen that before.
In all the years, I've seen a lot of talk shows.
I've not seen anybody do the, the
the seat to floor combo before.
So that's
I would love, like,
not only for you to tell me
like how you think I'm doing in this job,
but also what would Talk Soup
say about this nut ball of a show?
What would we? Right. Right.
What would we do.
Oh my God!
We'd have a lot of good material.
You wish you had me when you were at Talk Soup!
You wish you had a, like a,
a complete nutter butter like me!
I, there, you would be useful!
Yes I would!
I think I would.
But I will give you this last tip which is,
Please!
When I did my talk show, we had a book.
And everybody would sign the book.
Now I notice, I did not, either I was asked, you know,
we don't need Greg to sign the book,
or you may not have book.
I never thought to do that because
we launched in a pandemic and everybody was on Zoom
and nobody would come here!
And so,
Okay, we're gonna get you a book.
We're gonna get you a book.
(audience cheers)
And, and here's my second piece of advice.
I'll be the first one to sign your book!
But here's my second piece of advice,
is don't, don't then finish the show
and realize like a year later,
where's the book?
'Cause I don't the book from all the years I did later!
I had like a, like a huge book with everybody signed it
and stuff and I'm sure it said glowing things about me,
and I never found the book, so.
That's interesting, I just found an article
about this woman who has become a treasure huntress.
Maybe I need to call her and see
if she can help us track it down.
Really?
Yes! I just found this woman.
So she can find like, anything?
That's what she does.
Oh god, I gotta a lot of jobs for her, man.
(Drew laughs)
Well I think we know mission number one.
I'm gonna get the book, I'm gonna find this woman,
see if we can find your old book,
and now that we know each other we can be friends.
Okay, very good!
I love it.
(audience applauds)
Shining Vale is available for streaming
on Starz and the Starz app.
It is so awesome.
(theme music plays)